damn yep that's amazing let's talk about
a black hole it is a place where gravity
has had its ultimate Victory so it's
usually the collapsed core of a star so
you have this hyper dense region where
the gravity is so strong that light
can't escape back in the 1960s Stephen
Hawking realized that black holes
shouldn't actually be completely black
they should radiate originally we
thought that nothing could escape a
black hole because nothing can trouble
faster than light right now I think most
physicists believe that because you have
this Hawking radiation not only can the
energy get out but the information can
get out this is the other perplexing
thing about black holes the details of
what you threw into the black hole
somehow get out by this Hawking
radiation also so they get remembered
exactly damn
that's amazing